queda así reactivada la conexión aérea
entre Colombia y Venezuela con este
vuelo de la aerolínea satena que
aterrizó en el Aeropuerto Internacional
de maiquetía con 45 pasajeros a bordos
entre ellos periodistas colombianos y el
ministro de transporte Guillermo Reyes
quien aseguró que por ahora es una
frecuencia semanal pero están esperando
poder hacer dos vuelos semanales por su
parte del lado venezolano la aerolínea
turpiar Airlines viaja a Bogotá dos
veces por semana también fue consultado
sobre el tema de la aerolínea coviasa
recordemos la estatal venezolana
sancionada por el departamento del
tesoro de Estados Unidos el ministro
colombiano dijo que las autoridades
colombianas en Estados Unidos estaban en
conversaciones con el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos en reuniones
que tuvieron previamente sobre este tema
y que no es un tema cerrado están
pidiendo que levanten estas sanciones
para que conviasa pueda viajar a
territorio colombiano recordemos que
esta era una de las principales
peticiones por parte de la
administración Nicolás maduro y razón
por la cual no Se abrieron los vuelos el
pasado 26 de septiembre cuando se dio la
reapertura de la frontera entre Colombia
y Venezuela no se descarta que antes de
finalizar el año otras aerolíneas
colombianas puedan viajar a territorio
venezolano